Aaaah j'suis fatigué...
C'est tellement dur d'être youtubeur...
Et d'avoir une chaise cassée...
Si seulement je pouvais me détendre
Qu'on me masse
Comme ça
Pour détendre tous ces muscles...
Si gros et si imposants !
Et ben vu que personne veut me masser
J'men bats les couilles
J'ai trouvé une alternative
MR MASSAGY !
C'est un jeu ghetto
C'est un jeu ghetto que les choses soient claires entre nous
C'est un jeu ghetto mais
Euh en gros
On va rencontrer des filles
On va parler avec elles
On va faire connaissance
Et si on leur plait
Elles vont nous masser
Euh y a rien d'érotique ou de sexuel
Calmez vous direct les gars
Ils vont me masser à l'aide
D'un ustensile appelé
Manette de jeux vidéo.
Je suis curieux,
De voir si ça marche
J'ai besoin de me détendre
Me jugez pas
Y'en a qui se détendent en...
*Silence*
Me jugez pas !
Ah un p'tit tuto !
Alors première étape:
Poser vaillament.
Ok une fois qu'on a posé vaillament
On prend notre contrôleur
Et on le met sur notre nuque,
Et ensuite on laisse place à la personne qui doit...
Ok bon bref.
Ouais bon c'est un massage
Pour mec qui a pas trop d'amis quoi
Bon okay, c'est pas grave j'le prends pas mal.
"Hey Johnny c'est ton vieux pote Olivier ici....
je sais que t'aimes les massages, n'est-ce pas ?
Regarde cette application qui s'appelle 'Linger'.
C'est un site de rencontre où les gens vont te masser."
Bon je simplifie hein
*rire*
Mais pourquoi vous voulez toujours trouver une histoire
Dans les jeux vidéo
Des fois y'a
Juste pas d'histoire !
Faudrait pas créer une histoire autour du massage
Ok c'est parti !
On est sur Linger
Mon profil
Ça c'est mon profil
Ça c'est moi
Dorothy
15 étoiles ?
Et j'ai 0 étoile
Ah merde mais j'peux pas du coup
J'ai 0 étoile, je fais comment ?
Ah bah je peux avoir que elle
Ok
Bon ok ça marche
Oh oui !
Elle avait liké mon profil !
Putain vous auriez pu me demander la permission avant de scanner mon corps en 3D quand même
Ok donc on s'est donné rendez-vous
Dans un restaurant
Coucou mon nom est Rial
Mais tout le monde m'appelle Tuto
Tuto quoi ?
Tuto beauté ?
Tuto...
Oooooh !
Ah on est chaud !
Ah nan mais on est chaud !
Je t'observais de dehors depuis un moment
Donc..
t'étais en train de me mater
de l'autre côté de la fenêtre ?
Ouais c'est bien ça...
Euh ouais...
C'est pas bien ?
Pas du tout...
Moi aussi je le fais souvent...
Arrête !
Oh !
Tu es...
Exactement comme moi !
Oh mon dieu !
La manette a vibré hein
Starfoullah!
Eh si t'es comme moi je pense qu'on devrait jouer à un jeu rigolo
Par exemple que tu me masses
Et qu'en retour je ne te masse pas
Quelle est ton habitude la plus bizarre ?
euuuh...
- J'aime faire pipi dans la douche
- J'adore prétendre que je suis un chat et regarder les gens à travers les fenêtres
- Je veux pas jouer ce jeu
J'adore faire pipi dans la douche.
Faites pas genre... ça va!
Ok maintenant c'est à moi de lui poser une question
Et je vais lui poser la question suivante :
Aimes-tu les massages ?
Oh je ne pensais pas que tu allais me demander ca,
C'est parti !
Comment ça c'est parti ?
Who !
Elle masse bien.
Elle masse très très bien !
Squeezie en 2017 quand même hein !
On en est là !
Est-ce que cette position est confortable ?
Franchement non.
Ah attends c'est en train de me baiser le cou
Ça dois appuyer sur un truc où il faut pas
Le truc il est en train d'appuyer sur un point vital
Et de me couper le sang
Je vais mourir
Ok je fais quoi ensuite ?
C'est... tu me masses combien de temps en fait ?
Et est ce qu'elle vont toutes masser de la même manière ou pas ?
C'est ça la question !
Trop de questions, hein
J'ai ma... J'te jure j'ai ma dose !
C'est bon !
Lâche mon cou !
J'ai ma dose !
Le massage
Est terminé s'il te plait !
Allô ?
Ok stop !
C'est bon !
Ah mais c'est moi qui devait arrêter le massage ?
Putain mais mec !
J'aurais pu être là pendant deux jours quoi, sans déconner !
The tutorial : ton premier massage
Ouais ouais ouais ouais ouais...
Oh massage euh,
Massage euh, ouais d'enfant quoi
Non pas que je me sois déjà fais masser par un enfant,
Mais bon...
Quand j'étais enfant je massais de la même manière.
Allez suivant !
Du coup j'ai 3 étoiles!
Et je peux..
Rencontrer peut-être
Oui !
Martha !
C'est un maaatch !!
Nan, nan mais arrêtez de montrer mon corps
Même si vous l'avez modélisé ça se fais pas !
J'adore cette blague
Je m'y accroche beaucoup hein, comme vous pouvez le voir !
C'est un rendez-vous en ligne ?
Mais nan !
Mais c'est un sketch ?
Hi !
Eh t'as un nez mignon !
Nan il est bossu, un peu gros, mais bon ouais...
Merci, tu as un...
Nan en fait t'as rien de mignon.
Oh c'est bâtard ça !
Eh attends une minute !
T'as rien à voir avec ta photo de profil
Ah voila ça c'est vrai !
Cette photo de profil est un dessin
C'est pas une photo
Tu peux voir la différence entre une fiction et la réalité ?
Évidemment que je peux la voir
Et je peux te dire qu'avec toi je la vois !
Mais c'est un dessin de moi de quand j'avais 19 ans
Quand j'étais mannequin pour une marque de lingerie
Bah là t'as au moins 60 ans pour avoir autant changé !
Baaah !
Massagy x2
Ah, elle a kiffé ?
Je sais pas ce qu'elle a kiffé mais... ok.
Elle parle toute seule,
Elle fait un monologue depuis tout à l'heure et je gagne des points c'est incroyable !
Si ça pouvait être comme ça avec tous les humains,
Ce serait cool
Je crois que j'ai pas mal d'histoires
De mes années où j'étais modèle photo
Oui bah je vois ça ouais !
Après être allée à Paris,
On m'a contactée pour que je sois modèle photo pour hamburger
Donc j'ai mis un bikini rouge
Et je devais m'asseoir sur ce truc noir
On arrête tout, on arrête tout, on arrête tout...
je... je... avec la traduction ça va pas du tout
Je pense qu'on peut se voir en vrai
Et on va beaucoup rire
Je suis sûr qu'elle masse très bien en plus
On se voit ce soir
Ok.
Du coup tu masses plutôt comme un hamburger ou comme un modèle photo ?
Je ne sais pas lequel des deux massent mieux hein, d'ailleurs !
Bah c'est pareil...
Ah nan...
Oulà, mais elle fait un truc bizarre mon gars !
J'ai l'impression qu'elle va exploser !
Nan mais là ça vibre même pas
Ça... juste ça tremble
Nan mais mec !
T'as pas de force dans les poignets c'est ça ?
Parce que là ce que tu fais, c'est l'équivalent de si tu me marchais dessus avec tes genoux, en fait...
Allez c'est bon j'en ai assez, j'en ai assez
J'en ai assez vu
C'était...
C'était palpitant
Passionant
Euh...
Émouvant
Euh... allez
6 étoiles !
La suivante c'est qui ?
Nicole, 22 ans
Avec son chien qui se prépare à uriner...
Y'a pas de soucis
Alors, "Johnny a rencontré Nicole dans les bois, au milieu de la nuit."
D'accord tu t'es crue à la Japan Expo
Mais... c'est pas grave.
"Hey Johnny, je suis très contente que tu sois là ! Ça représente beaucoup  pour moi."
"Je sais que c'était long de venir ici, mais ça valait le coup."
OK...
"J'adore ton odeur !"
Commence par t'éloigner...
Mesure de sécurité.
"T'as déjà senti quelque chose qui te rappelle un bon souvenir ?"
Ouais ! L'odeur du sang
Le mec le plus ghetto d'Europe !
C'est faux hein, c'est faux !
"Quand je sens l'odeur du crayon, ça me rappelle mon enfance."
"Quand je rote, ça me rappelle mon 'breakfast'."
Ouais...
"Quand je sens des pommes, ça me rappelle ma mère !"
Bah le crayon
Bah c'est du x3
Apparemment c'était le bon truc
Nicole est partie en courant pour chasser un écureuil
Dans le doute je vais peut être euh...
Installer Meetic et ne plus aller sur euh...
Linger.
Ah c'est un écureuil tout mignon !
"Je dois le suivre"
Attends la meuf elle se...
Elle s'enjaille toute seule !
Je réponds même plus et je gagne quand même des points
Alors que c'est pas moi qui lui fait du bien...
C'est elle-même qui se fait du bien...
C'est pas grave..
"Nicole est partie pour chasser un gros écureuil."
C'est bien, c'est bien.
Mais faites ça, faites ça quand vous êtes en rendez-vous, y'a pas de soucis !
Partez chasser un truc et revenez !
Mais en revenant la fille sera plus là et tu vas devoir payer l'addition
Bon, tu me masses ou pas ?
À un moment on va aller droit au but !
Putain elle est repartie chasser un écureuil
Mais putain !
Masse moi !
Regardez c'est un monologue...
Regardez je... j'en peux plus..
J'aime les canards
Voila c'est une très bonne réponse...
Je gagne des points...
J'ai même plus besoin de lire ce qu'elle dit
Nan !
Naaan !
J'ai spammé, NAAAAN !
Oh nan j'ai cliqué sur une réponse où il dit:
"Attends y'a un autre truc qui bouge...
... et c'est dans mon pantalon."
Et là elle est partie direct la queue entre les jambes
Parce qu'elle avait vraiment une queue si vous aviez pas remarqué.
Allez vas-y masse moi fais péter !
Alors...
Là on est sur un massa-
WOW !
EH ÇA BOMBARDE !
OH LA VACHE !
On se croirait dans un avion avec des turbulences !
J'étais en train de m'endormir...
Ok c'est bon !
C'est bon maintenant je me casse des bois
Tu me masses plus jamais
Tu me touches plus jamais
Mais on passe à autre chose
Alors...
Est-ce qu'il y en a une à 10 étoiles ?
10 étoiles, 10 étoiles...
C'est elle
Oh, elle a l'air chelou
"Johnny est dans un vaisseau spatial au milieu de nulle part."
D'accord...
On part sur ça...
Attends j'espère c'est pas l'équivalent féminin du mec de Striptease
Qui fabrique sa soucoupe volante pour aller dans l'espace ?
"Faut pas croire que c't'engin est né du ciel...
... comme ça...
qu'il est né sans rien, hein.
Faut pas oublier qu'j'ai pas fais d'plan...
... pour faire c't'engin."
Je rentre pas dedans sinon, hein
Clairement
"Oh hé ! Tu es tellement beau !"
"Faisons des bébés ici et maintenant !"
Nan.
"Wait WHAT ! JACKPOT !"
"Allez c'est parti !"
Vas-y...
Bah voila...
Rapide, efficace, pas cher
Merci de rencontrer [...]
5/5 sur le Play Store
C'est pas dégueu'...
C'est pas dégueu' !
C'est des petits accoups
J'ai l'impression qu'elle est en train de faire l'amour à mon cou
C'est très bizarre.
Attends je vous la pose
Vous allez voir c'est incroyable
Vous allez vous rendre compte
Bon merci pour ce massage
C'était genial
Alors euh...
10 étoiles, Mayo !
Qui possède dans sa cuillère, de la mayonnaise...
C'est un excellent jeu de mots
Je sens que cette personne va me plaire
"Oh hé ! Mon nom est Mayo."
"Bienvenue dans mon appartement"
Ah d'accord Mayo c'était la mayonnaise dans la cuillère,
C'était pas la meuf.
Super drôle..
"J'ai été très chanceuse qu'il y ait un 'match' entre nous sur Linger...
...Tu as de belles fesses."
Merci.
Tu ne mettra jamais de mayonnaise dessus je peux te le dire
Mais c'est une mayonnaise mec..
Qu'est ce que je suis censé dire à une mayonnaise ?
J'arrête pas de...
De faire genre je l'aime bien.
Attends !
Peut-être que la mayo va masser mieux que les autres !
Ok j'ai réussi !
"Damn, Johnny. Il vient d'ouvrir le pot."
What the fuck...
Vas-y masse moi la mayonnaise !
Fais moi rêver la mayonnaise !
Fais-moi kiffer !
Oh ! On dirait qu'il fait le...
Tu sais le truc avec les mains là !
Comme ça !
Le truc que je sais faire !
C'est exactement ça la sensation!
Attends il masse mieux que les filles !
Sur Tinder cherche pas, hein !
Si tu vois une photo de pot de mayonnaise,
Match direct
C'est moins d'embrouilles en plus
OOOOOOH !
Eh voila les amis c'est déja la fin de cette video
Si il y a une utilité secondaire au jeu...
gardez ça pour vous.
Bref on oublie ça, on oublie ça...
N'hésitez pas à aimer la vidéo si elle vous a plu.
Je suis bouche-bée.
Je suis bouleversé.
Je suis tétanisé.
Je vous conseille
De tester
Quoique le jeu coûte 5 euros, en fait nan...
Franchement tu mets ton téléphone en vibreur,
Tu le poses là,
Tu t'appelles avec ta ligne fixe en boucle c'est le même effet.
En tout cas on se retrouve très vite pour une prochaine vidéo
Merci d'avoir regardé
Portez vous bien
Tchao tout le monde
Je retourne me faire masser
À bientôt !